hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong my name is Mark
Ellis Jacqueline Coley taking her sweet
time getting back into the studio and
deservedly so she's on a little vacay
from all the award season coverage
probably on her couch right down the
street where I was playing video games
that's either here nor there because we
love having Jacqueline here but in her
stead we have two-thirds of the world
girls that are going to be celebrating
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 with us as
we get set for Guardians 3 which comes
out as of this release tomorrow May 5th
so that's pretty exciting for all of us
and I'm very excited to have Steph Sabra
and Doreen Ariano back here in studio
darina you know where is a world girl
and also a DJ composer and Steph and
I've I've I this is on my sheet as well
as me knowing this Steph is kind of like
ego's a living planet Steph is a living
Vibe yeah totally okay yeah but then
uh welcome ladies thanks for being here
thanks for having us yeah so exciting to
be here as always I do miss Jacqueline
but I love Mark and I obviously love
Steph there's so nothing like staring
into dorina's eyes yes shout out to uh
Roxy having fomo yeah Roxy was in here a
couple weeks ago the other the other
world girl which is the horrible way to
say that there's no other world girl you
know you know you're all in a world of
John Paul George's and rangos you're all
either John or Paul you can pick one of
you you can be George if you want she's
definitely here
dorita's here death is a Vibe y'all been
giving stuff whirls recently what have
we been up to uh we went to Super
Nintendo World which was excellent if
you haven't been uh I know there's rides
and foods and less to do but the best
thing was jamming on those pow blocks oh
so you can actually do it you can
actually smash them yeah and get coins
and stuff you need to spend a lot of
Moolah on this bracelet okay which You
Gotta Give the man something I guess but
it's fun well we went to uh we went we
we have this new show that you all can
catch on YouTube called on the street
where I just interview people on the
street about movies any topic whatsoever
so the first one we did was a Universal
CityWalk and we were so hyped from Mario
we couldn't necessarily even if we got
access to be in front of Super Mario
World it was such a mad house over there
with just like people going in and out
all over the place you really couldn't
get any attractions we were interviewing
people outside the friendly confines and
people were so losing their minds as to
how much fun they were having people
loved it and it looked way cooler than I
thought it was going to yeah it's like
an adult playground I mean it's meant
for kids but come on I mean adults all
of us that grew up with Super Nintendo I
agree with the kids our minds go various
places when you say adult playground
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah no
there's no strippers or anything no
strippers you don't get any sexy Yoshi
or anything even though Yoshi's
obviously Yoshi is sexy there's a lot of
sexy oh yes stuff and I fight over
Yoshi there's a lot of sexiness in the
movie we're talking about because upon
rewatching Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
very horny movie yes which is wow James
Gunn ma'am yes a lot of imagery a lot of
overt references a lot of subtle hints
and so we're gonna talk about this movie
because again the new new movie comes
out as of this recording tomorrow but we
just get excited this time of year to
see something that is in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's summertime big
Blockbuster tent pull movies you expect
to see some MCU Glory but Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 as I remembered it it
was a movie that was fun it was good it
I don't remember it blowing me away I
just remember it being like ah okay that
maybe was a little too long I liked it
it wasn't as good as the first was sort
of the way I felt walking out of the
theater so I have sense upon re-watching
this adjusted my opinion of the film but
I want to throw it to you ladies first
so Steph Rotten Tomatoes currently on
the Tomato Meter has Guardians of the
Galaxy Volume 2 85 percent certified
fresh is the Tomato Meter right or is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong I think the Tomato
Meter is just right on this one I really
feel like it's a solid b-plus I know
that's up to negotiation by some
teachers 85 percent they're just the
worst that's a B plus in my mind you
round up yeah yeah so B plus I I
absolutely love this movie I liked it
better upon the second watch actually
too so it's on the honor roll it's
second honors for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 for Steph dorina how do we
feel about it I am as always the outlier
and uh I actually think Guardians of the
Galaxy 2 is amazing and way better than
the first one which I hate it compared
to most people wow all right I hate it
yes so the Tomato Meter is wrong in
terms of it's just not high enough
correct it's just right according to
Steph well because the first one is only
a little bit higher right the first one
is 92 percent why do you brought that up
92 certified fresh which is still only
good for the seventh highest MCU movie
on the Tomato Meter number one is Black
Panther you have uh end game you have uh
no I think homecoming is way up there so
guardians of galaxy 92 it's only seventh
best this one volume two smack dab in
the middle of the MCU as far as the
Tomato Meter it's ranked number 16 mean
currently but those rankings changing
all the time Eternal is bringing up the
rear at 47 percent
um I feel like rotten tomatoes is wrong
on this one yes because I think 85 is
too low correct and I did not feel that
way when I walked out of the theater
seeing this movie initially re-watching
it I don't know what bad mood I was in
that day yeah I had so I had a blast
watching it I got more into the emotions
of the story I was laughing by myself
well I had me and my little Rocket
Raccoon Molly they're with me and it was
I had a great time watching this it was
a movie there was actually a movie with
and it's a character story unlike the
first one I know it's weird that that's
the criticism too much character yes
what's a movie exactly
element for us plus you had Kurt Russell
and sometimes he DH Kurt Russell which
looked fantastic so yeah we're getting
all that stuff very excited to talk to
this movie The synopsis The Guardians of
Galaxy Vol 2.
um I'll kind of piggyback off the ladies
and say it's a relationship movie where
you have Peter Quill kind of realizing
who his father is ego The Living Planet
played by Kurt Russell is that good or
bad you have Gamora nebula who are
working on their sibling rivalry and
then you also have Drax who sort of made
a bond with mantis you have rocket who
is sort of helping to steer Baby Groot
along in this adventure and then we have
yondu who is the surrogate Daddy to
Peter but was he just using Peter did he
really have feelings for him as his son
a lot of these questions get answered it
leaves a lot open to interpretation oh
Stallone's in this too there's a lot to
talk about before we get into movie talk
let's toss it to our good buddy Tim Ryan
for our segment two minutes with Tim
he's going to tell us what the critics
were saying at the time of this film's
release way back we were so young in
2017. hit it Tim
[Music]
first off I want to share something with
a group one of my absolute favorite
villains in the Marvel universe is ego
The Living Planet
so much so that ego was my AOL Instant
Messenger Avatar that's how far we go
back so I was delighted when I found out
that ego would be the bad guy in the
second Guardians of the Galaxy movie and
I have to say I enjoyed the movie quite
a bit with one complaint not enough ego
anyway Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
found the MCU at a moment where it
seemed they could do no wrong they could
build a commercially successful
critically acclaimed mini franchise out
of some of its goofiest Heroes Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 is certified fresh
at 85 on the Tomato Meter with 426
reviews and it has an 87 audience score
and just for comparison the original
Guardians of the Galaxy from 2014 is
certified fresh at 92 percent so what
did the critics have to say in a fresh
review no minnow of movie mom wrote that
it was still delightfully off kilter
still deliciously irreverent and still
delectively scored with 70s pop songs
however in a rotten review Todd McCarthy
of The Hollywood Reporter wrote
Guardians of the Galaxy plays like a
second ride on a roller coaster that was
a real kick the first time around but
feels very been there done that now the
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus reads
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2's
action-packed plot dazzling visuals and
irreverent humor add up to a sequel
that's almost as fun if not quite as
thrillingly fresh as its predecessor so
that's Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2.
let's kick it back to Mark a man who can
say I am Groot in two three languages
maybe more back to you thank you for
those honors Tim that I cannot live up
to I want to get into that freshness for
a minute so Brian go ahead and hit the
music for movie talk
there might be a thing with me and like
the way I conduct my life as to why I
like this movie so much more on my
second re-watch is because I don't want
to say I've strayed too far from my MCU
fandom like I still enjoy the movies but
I have felt a fatigue in comic book
movies in general in the last couple
years and so putting this one on I did
it felt fresh again to me and so maybe
when I saw the movie in the theater I
was just inundated with MC after MCU
movie we just kicked off phase three a
couple films prior to this and so maybe
I just wasn't in the right headspace to
enjoy this movie like I was now even
though I feel superhero fatigue I felt
none of that re-watching this movie
stuff yeah I re-watching it I was like
oh my God this is like a really great
funny movie but laugh out loud funny
every time and James Gunn is just I I
feel like I've become a bigger and
bigger fan of his comedy yeah but this
one I feel like it's so unique like such
a unique take on everyone has some some
form of daddy issues or parental issues
like generational trauma that you have
to break the mold of but they did it in
a funny way I I just really it is
refreshing like after all of these empty
movies that have come out I feel like
coming back to this one you're like oh
this one's this one is different and
these characters are different because
they they're in space it's a little more
like there's more area to play in the
characters yeah and by volume two now
Dorena we they know each other and so we
can just get right into whatever the
action is and we don't take that whole
First Act to kind of get them their
introductions and that kind of Rocky
beginning now they're just out there
guarding the Galaxy and shooting up
these giant monsters and having a blast
doing it I think that comedy maybe rubs
some people the wrong way where it was
too funny and not serious enough for
this Intergalactic Quest that we're
going on it was actually funny on like
the first one so the thing is is the the
first one wait why yeah let's get into
this what was your issue with the first
one before we get into the second one
look I didn't hated hate it I don't want
like the Fanboys coming after me it's
okay it's okay we don't like the same
movies but I was I definitely remember
watching the screening and everybody
around me laughing the entire time and I
felt like MTV's Daria where she just
sits during the theater just looking at
everybody feeling like an alien so I
felt like actually from space and so man
that's a good point I left twice in the
first movie and I actually felt that
Star-Lord even though Chris Pratt you
know good actor he was trying to be Kurt
Russell from the 80s right he was trying
to be like Big Trouble in Little China
Kurt Russell how correct you were yes uh
and actually I think he actually ended
up suggesting to James Gunn to hire Kurt
Russell for ego's character
um so um I I don't know I felt old and I
was not into it and the second one I was
so pleasantly surprised because it was a
character story like it's actually
um you know like Fast and the Furious
it's about family right it's um it might
be the most Vin Diesel movie about
family
exactly also one big thing as we know
that MCU has always had a really bad
villain problem for so long until we met
Thanos it's actually until we met ego
right ego it was the first MCU villain
that I was like this is a real villain
that is actually complex like ego is
basically the worst part of all the
humans and the guardian's character like
obviously car Russell played him so well
but not only is he he's supposed to be
charismatic and Charming but he's a
total psychopath he's a narcissist
that's trying to not take over the world
like Thanos like he's actually trying to
make the univ or create a universe to be
like him right which is good yeah which
is the most totally exactly it's the
most egotistical narcissistic thing
right and and uh and I mean the fact
that he only cares to have his son
around to become more powerful right
talk about daddy issues yeah I mean but
when you look at the the casting of Kurt
Russell in this movie and that's how we
kick the film off is like him him back
in time where it's the Kurt Russell that
we all sort of knew if you grew up in
the 80s and 90s you're like oh yeah
that's the guy that's one of the biggest
movie stars on the planet so it's a
stroke of Genius to cast him whether it
was feige or James Gunn or whether it
was Chris Pratt suggesting it because we
implicitly trust a guy like Kurt Russell
when you see him on the big screen it's
almost like seeing a Tom Cruise that's
why What Lies Beneath was such a genius
movie that zemeckis did because he cast
Harrison Ford in a way that we thought
we knew Harrison Ford until a turn
happens and all of a sudden we have no
idea who this guy is anymore same thing
with Kurt Russell because like you want
to believe in Kurt Russell we all want
to be in that car next to Kurt Russell
in the beginning of the film and the
de-aging looked so good big screen small
screen that was 1980s Kurt Russell as
far as I'm concerned yes I mean who
wouldn't want Kurt Russell to be their
daddy Mark yeah I mean he can be my pal
he can be I won't say what I wouldn't do
with Kurt Russell but speaking of
Daddy's quick question yeah Thanos we
get a little bit more backstory on him
in this movie not a great not a great
dad so both of these girls are snatched
up from different planets yeah so you
have Gamora and you have nebula and and
the the torture of nebula in this movie
or at least what you hear about her
upbringing is just so heartbreaking
where every time she battled Gamora and
lost she became more of a machine and
less of a human but she still retains
some of that emotion and some of that
Humanity that Gamora is trying to bring
out in this movie so that's another
through line that you just get so
engaged with or at least I did the
second time and I don't know why I
didn't feel that the first time yeah
nebula for sure I and Gamora I I go back
and forth between her and Drax of who is
my favorite character okay the more in
this movie just had more to do than the
first movie for me where I'm like oh
she's actually a superhero like or an
antagonist like she's so cool The Way
She Moves I love the the way they did
her movement but the relationship with
nebula is really cool because they're
like two adopted sisters who had a bad
adoptive father who like made them hate
each other which is kind of what happens
in society today and it was like and
that actress is Scottish I'm like what
Aaron Dylan yeah
yeah I mean it's it's an incredible cast
in their relationship I think is
predicated upon how bad their upbringing
was and so it it actually made me
appreciate the awesome mix vol 1 tape
the cassette tape that Peter Quill has
and why he's so protective of it because
you are in his backstory in this movie
too where it was of ego in in a human
form impregnating his mom right and he
loves his mom dearly he lost his mom he
misses her his mom made that tape for
him and so when his Walkman gets smashed
in this movie by eagle it's like you're
looking at it and you say oh that's like
his that's the one thing in his
childhood that he can kind of go on to
that was positive and nebula and Gamora
don't have that and so that's why
there's this conflict here but we still
have this sort of sun more more of a
sunshiny disposition I would say that
Peter has versus Gamora but then dorina
we have their relationship that is also
very gradually but sometimes those end
up being the best ones yeah no and
unspoken well and that's that's exactly
the difference between the first one and
the second one to me is that you get to
explore these two sisters actually not
reconciling but at least coming to some
sort of truce to be like you know what
our dad was an so let's it's
Okay We're Not Gonna ruin the wedding
anymore exactly right yes correct um and
then also I mean the the fact that you
have uh you know Peter he was upset
because he got his uh Walkman smash but
ego specifically spoilers says I
actually put that brain tumor in your
mom yeah that's like I mean that's one
of the best quotes in the movie because
you're just like oh you're a jerk like
you actually like killed the woman that
you fell in love with because you're
such an arrogant prick that you don't
care you you didn't want her as a
distraction to be able to like you know
become this like so Celestial God or
whatever so so talk about daddy issues
there and then every every single
character has this journey where they're
actually finding themselves and going
through their like exploring their like
childhood trauma or whatever like
whatever they went through and then
finding each other in family right like
you talk about how many people like this
this is why this movie is so amazing and
relatable to me because how many people
find unconditional love outside a blood
family right like they actually find it
in friends and like that's the that's
the whole point of this movie is the
Guardians coming together to be like
you're my family like our our actual
blood family messed up let's come
together and like we are the family and
that's and we're gonna save the world
together so when I moved to LA uh I was
introduced this concept of friendsgiving
Right Where I again I had I was very
lucky I had a really cool family and so
we just do Thanksgiving every year and I
had no idea what a friendsgiving was
this movie is a friendsgiving yes where
you realize I don't really want to go
home there's some stuff going on there
whether it's my sister or I have a
horrible stepdad or my old man is an
actual Planet he's a total egotistical
Maniac I just want to hang out with my
friends that's what a friend's giving is
that's what this movie is the whole
movie is every character sort of
figuring out that wherever I came from
is one thing I survived to this point
and I am an adult and I can make my own
decisions as to who I keep around me who
I keep in my company and you see it with
every character I think one of the
things that when I first saw this movie
in theater Steph it didn't turn me off
because Dave Batiste is so good at
delivering humorous lines as Drax but I
felt like Drax was just comic relief
and he's hilarious but re-watching the
movie everything he says is funny in the
moment but then you go back and you look
at it and there's sort of a point to it
where he can he's sort of just speaking
things out loud but when you go back and
watch it you're like he's getting deeper
than I think I gave him credit for
definitely that's why I love Drax
because he like he has sensitive nipples
and I'm so appreciative that he's
letting the world know he's being
vulnerable but he has that moment with
in the relationship with mantis that I
think really exposes his vulnerable side
in his true side and then when she's
like trying to feel his emotions and
she's like there's a lot of sadness like
it was the first time she found her deep
sadness and then you did get his
backstory about how he saw his wife and
daughter being killed so when you add it
all together his character has a ton of
impact yes yes I mean it's truly
um you know these these superheroes
spend most of their this movie talking
about their feelings
there's plenty of that in the movie too
but the difference was like the first
one is literally a plot to
um basically take us to the rest of the
expanded universe right to like take us
to Infinity War this second one is not
that the second movie is about family is
about the characters like I always say
the the real Infinity Stones are the
friends we made along the way
that's a great point and but you also
make a good observation about most of
the sequels in the MCU that we've had
whether it's Iron Man 2 or it's Avengers
Age of Ultron or even like something
like I would say Winter Soldier less so
Civil War more overt where those sequels
the the first one is like hey meet Iron
Man this is what he's about second ones
are like okay now we need to use this
movie that is based on a successful
property that we know as a conduit to
more things and ingratiating more
elements into the universe Guardians
Volume 2 does that but it doesn't do the
thing where it tries to get so big and
we're in a vast unit Universe already it
doesn't try to overstep its bounds and
set a bunch of stuff up for Infinity War
right which was right around the corner
I mean again this is phase three I think
Doctor Strange was the movie that was
immediately before Guardians and then
the movie immediately afterwards was
Spider-Man homecoming yeah I completely
agree it's one of the things I really
like about the way they did the sequel
is that it made me more invested in the
character story so now it's like I'm
more excited about volume 3 than I was
about volume two me too if that makes
sense because I'm like oh okay it's kind
of a prequel in a sense that we really
got to know who they are and why they
are that's a great point and then I'm
like let me go for the ride now like I'm
with this family right close up the
chapter and we were actually doing my my
show on the street we were doing some
interviews at WonderCon last month and I
was asking people which movie they're
most hyped for this year this coming
summer everybody was saying Guardians
three to the point where like we'd bring
in a new person to talk to him like Hey
can you say anything about Guardians
three
something else on there so one of the
things about Guardians 3 though is that
I think a lot of people like
trepidations about is like are we is
everybody going to make it out of this
thing do we have to off somebody I mean
it was so emotional when we lost Gamora
in Infinity War it's hard to go through
that again most of the people I talked
to on the street think if somebody's
gonna eat it it's gonna be Rocket
Raccoon and I can't allow that to happen
no he's the worst dorina
for him so much I'm like wow I I really
do like she's the chewy of the group
like everyone calls him like like he's
like when Princess Leia called Chewie
the carpet it's like this is that was
wrong that was wrong of my fearless
leader Princess Leia and everyone who
calls him like what do you call it
Trasher you should get throat punched
are we gonna have a campaign to cancel
Leia because she called Chewbacca I
can't have it it's on tape she was Mary
Poppins in space she was already
canceled so we get Mary Poppins yeah
how about Young
great
Ness in this movie that like just it
just completely tickle me not the least
of which is supported by rocket right
rocket delivers a lot of greatness he's
is Bradley Cooper's rocket is way more
tolerable in the second one I will say
that he's so good I like oh but I think
Drax is gonna die and I'm really upset
about it
yes because Dave Batista has talked
about not you know he doesn't want to be
Drax forever and he didn't even want his
role to be as big as it was in the
second one until he read the script and
he's like okay I get why my Character
Matters more I just feel like bummer but
I'm so upset well I mean hopefully I'm
wrong he can join his family you know
again I'm not saying that facetiously we
all it's very sad what you've been
through Mr Destroyer but he's just so
goddamn funny he's so he's really great
maybe not excellent
um you also might figure out Rocket's
origin story in Guardians three yeah so
you guys love him I mean I actually like
all of them he's just my he's
just full
like yeah well when the first one Groot
is trying to take care of him and then
they reverse rules in this one where he
actually becomes baby groots like you
know yeah exactly and there's a really
cool parallel between what ego had done
to Peter's mom where it's like I'm gonna
implant this cancer in you because I
can't stand to like to feel love like
I'm a Celestial being I need to be above
all this
um and then what rocket it's really
rocket because he steals these batteries
and so then we get to pretty much
implant explosives into ego in the same
way that the cancer
and so it's kind of like you're getting
you're reaping what you sow you gotta
taste your own medicine right there and
Rockets stealing the batteries just the
way he goes about his business is so
goddamn funny to me but it also makes
sense from he he's chewy but he's also
Han he's got that Smuggler where he's
just out for himself but he finds more
dare I say for a trash Panda Humanity in
this in this movie and one of my
favorite lines is in reference to rocket
after mantis first meets him and she's
on the ship she's laughing at it because
she calls him the crabby puppy
it's so cute I want to die it's a close
second to my favorite all-time rocket
reference which is when Thor is calling
him sweet rabbit and infinity
totally but man's a solid runner-up I
love the introduction of mantis as a
character is an excellent addition to
the team too I forgot that we didn't
meet her until volumes too I was like
why is everybody acting like they don't
know mantis she's one of the best parts
of the movie totally she's such an
awesome depiction I know that the
creator of mantis is like this is
nothing like the right comic book
character I like this mantis yeah she's
like the the universe can relate yeah
she's the most powerful one yes and and
she can even keep ego at Bay for a
little bit my God wouldn't we all love
to have a mantis in our life her laugh
it's like rb3's laugh it just makes you
want to go with her I just want her by
my bedside at around 11 p.m and just all
she has to do is touch me I don't need
to take any pills I need to do anything
just and I'm and I'm out for eight hours
can I can we talk about a couple of
things number one how amazing this movie
looks because compared to a lot of MCU
movies that are not in color like this
movie is in color like this movie is
gorgeous cinematography and then also I
know we mentioned yondu really quick but
that was one of the best I think endings
and not just an MCU movie but any
superhero movie I think it's one of the
most emotional beautiful endings and for
some reason you don't see it a lot in
cinema where it's it's not the real
father but they clearly are the daddy
you know it's like sure ego is
technically my father according to the
letter of the law yondu raised me more
than anyone else did and it was cool
seeing yondu even soften and be like
well okay look yeah I use the excuse
that let's keep this kid around he's
good for stealing but he really was
protecting him and trying to protect all
the eagles other kids for a long time to
the point where it got ego was sort of
the reason why yondu got kicked out of
this of of the rabbits because they
thought he was trafficking kids and it's
like no I'm trying to protect them from
like the worst dad on Earth made be next
to Thanos right the labels are so unfair
he gets called a child Smuggler
yeah that's like you hear it and you're
like oh brother I'm gonna need a lot of
evidence to combat this right and then
on the other side ego is just like
screwing the world and like if he was a
woman he would be called a totally
right what is the line actually when
yondu sacrifices himself for Pete and
saves Peter's life he actually says he
may have been your father boy but he
wasn't your daddy great line right yeah
and and that like as soon as you see
like there's like there's one spacesuit
I'm already thinking Armageddon I'm like
all right who's gonna be yeah he's gonna
be Ben Affleck in this particular
situation so I thought that was that was
really well played and and the movie
wraps up and it's just got that
emotional sort of climax from The
Sisterhood of nebula and Gamora which is
slowly being repaired from Peter
realizing that he already found his
family and that's one of the most
heartbreaking scenes in this movie and
it's one of my favorites is when he's
trying to explain to Gamora which I mean
he's got a fair point he's like I've
been looking for my family this whole
time now I found my dad and by the way
my dad is Kurt Russell
who wouldn't want to hang out with that
guy for the rest of my life but then
Gamora reminds him I thought you already
had found your family oh I get chills
thinking about it so good so if we're
doing like best scenes in the movie it
can be like a fun action sequence it
could be something emotional starting
with you Dorena I mean honestly it's
it's because I messed up is uh it's
basically when um ego tells uh Peter
that he's responsible for Meredith for
Meredith quell's death right like I mean
because that's when that's when Peter
gets so angry rightfully so and ego is
so full of himself that he thinks oh I'm
gonna tell him then and she'll be fine
with it and he'll still conquer the
Galaxy with me and I'm like no you idiot
like that that was such a good example
of a a literal narcissist you know
weakness of thinking like oh no this
will be fine because everybody loves me
because I'm like so full of myself and I
showed you the power that you would have
taking over the universe with me and
since I won I killed your mom but look
at all this power exactly and then Peter
obviously is like f you I have family
already
because Darth Vader's basically there
he's like come on man we can I'll be
honest Darth Vader makes a pretty damn
good pitch
like I'm not saying I'm not just would
you join him yeah I mean I'd prefer to
have my hand back like if we could have
done away with all the lightsaber fights
Darth Vader makes a good pitch he's like
don't worry about the emperor you and me
will rule the galaxy yeah that's that's
a fair point not a bad recruiting Point
much better than ego because ego
basically opens with like hey man we're
powerful I killed your mom but uh
I I could I could have just put like a
bullet in your mom's head I made her
suffer I'm so sorry about that look at
how powerful we are though don't worry
about love Yeah like build a Pac-Man
like with me forever which is also a
nice touch the Pac-Man was great great
touch uh but for favorite scene to go I
like have two top ones yeah the one with
uh mantis and Drax at the after they'd
been going back and forth about how how
Drax thinks she's hideous and so
disgusting and he's like throwing up in
his mouth thinking about even being with
her and finally she's just trying to get
the job done she's like I don't want I
think you're disgusting I don't even
like your kind like I don't know and it
just is like I love how they don't take
things personal because they're so uh
just don't understand sarcasm and it
would be kind of nice and refreshing to
live in a world where we're like yeah I
think
yeah yeah but like that's cool I don't
like you either and then the second one
was the breakout singing scene from the
ship yondu ship when he got his new the
uh Finn prototype and just went Ham on
everyone and then laser laser face got
his like the ending oh taser face I
forgot about the taser yeah
oh my God this movie's just got its
endless laughs and and I think that's
why maybe the time I was just expecting
a straight up action I have no idea with
that I was a in 2017.
yeah you guys all knew this no I didn't
know
wait so maybe this has to do about my
like relationship
once I met my ego The Living Planet I
could fly that is your Kurt Russell
that's my yondu yeah that's right
come on let's play catch
that scene was great so good yeah the
catching too it's like I mean that's
really living out childhood trauma and
like the what you would want to do as a
young boy I assume everything you lack
you're like oh this is actually what
it's supposed to be like interesting
around it it feels like a very nuclear
looking Ball but let's toss around my
dad I guess I'm Celestial I can protect
it okay here's my question for y'all
coming out of this movie do does Peter
have any powers left or do you think
that that ego is right they're like okay
so it you kill me all of this Celestial
stuff is gone you think maybe there's
still a little bit of that Celestial
fairy dust somewhere inside quill that
could probably help him out of a future
Guardians type Jam I think it's gone and
that's why we saw him be an idiot in
Infinity War
yeah and and maybe I forgive the the
raccoons of the world more easily than I
do the humans because he really bothered
me in Infinity War when again he let his
motions get the best of him like he's
he's a human and we know how emotional
he is and how much he loves Gamora when
Thanos is just like kind of talking to
him and he gets and and he gets Peter to
break and then that's how Thanos uses
him at the end of infinity War it
bothered the hell out of me because he's
like dude I know he killed your girl
this is the whole galaxy man I got it I
gotta have you put those feelings aside
maybe this movie softened my take on
that yeah I I do think he gets his
powers back and maybe like a Hercules
type thing where he has to go through
like 27 different
challenges to gain his power back
um I yeah this move like speculating
about what could happen in Guardians
three not really the job of the show but
it just it's there's so much to look at
as far as where we've been in the MCU
since Volume 2 came out and like I said
we had end game and I just feel like
we're still kind of not not Treading
Water because we've made some strides
with some cool new characters that we've
been introduced to but it just hasn't
felt the same since then so I'm really
looking forward to Guardians 3 to maybe
bring that magic back is that too much
pressure to put on a movie oh man James
Gunn um I you know this is I know this
is not Marvel but the suicide squad was
brilliant we loved that Peacemaker is
great yeah it was great exactly so
excellent I um even with the MCU and
superhero General fatigue uh Guardians 3
is a James Gunn movie so I'm looking
forward to it and I actually think the
biggest challenge is making the
soundtrack even better because the
second the second volume has a new
better soundtrack than the first which
is crazy yeah I mean you got ELO you got
George Harrison
yeah My Sweet Lord is great and I and I
was thinking about the usage of a band
like Fleetwood Mac who just had
notorious breakups and relationship
issues that being the song that that
sort of sets us off on our adventure
with Peter going towards ego but then
also him breaking away from ego so very
kind of Lindsey Stevie there was it the
chain right it was the chain yeah yeah
so pretty good soundtrack that first
guardian's volume pretty pretty
raspberry topped here yeah yeah very
good they released what the third
soundtrack is or James Gunn did like all
the tracks and stuff and um it looks
great all I know the one that I remember
off top my head is it's spacehog for a
band from the 90s has a song called In
the meantime and it's such a great
Intergalactic feeling song that it's
perfect for this movie but is it Mr Blue
Sky by Electric Light Orchestra there's
very few songs that are exactly there's
very few but in one last baby grew in
the intro like the beginning when he's
like handling the music I thought that
was such a smart device but then baby
Groot I feel like was used so well in
the movie I haven't said that like just
such a great use of the character and at
the end when that one of the yondu's
guys was like the worst to him yelling
in his face and like abusing this cute
little Feller and then he just like took
snatched him up and smashed him on the
ground at the end I was like let's go
baby Groot I love that it's it's almost
like every other Guardian is groot's
parent at the beginning of the movie
because they're all like fighting this
huge monster but they're all kind of
checking on crew to the same time when
Gamora is like fighting she just looks
over it like like with her game face on
then she sees grid she just gives him
like oh yeah it's just adorable so much
cooler than baby Yoda um
there might be an accident in the
parking garage okay let me do that to
you then darina brought it up I'm gonna
like the end of the movie The Good Son
Steph you're holding baby Yoda they
don't have their powers you're holding
baby Yoda and Baby Groot on the edge of
a cliff you can only save one
who are you dropping I'm dropping green
honest they're like hunting grew off the
mouth
of him I know you're right you're way
more useful to the Galaxy
he's very useful but he's not more
useful
steps obsessed with broken yeah look
Grog is adorable but as I've said in uh
in stand-up over the years I don't trust
a 50 year old baby whose only dad is a
bounty hunter that seems like a recipe
for disaster when you have those kind of
powers so maybe I'll stick with the tree
I'm like Steve curl and anchor man I'm
like you're not Ron you're not Yoda
you ain't your daddy who's a good daddy
well I don't know Yoda probably wasn't
ever a daddy no they're not allowed to
do that exactly now the reason why Luke
should have gone with Darth Vader but
anyway that's an argument for a
different day the one that I want to
close out movie talk with for y'all is
let's pick our favorite characters of
the Guardians
so just the core Guardians first who's
your favorite who do we got I mean I'm
kind of with Steph I think Drex and
Gamora are the best ones um and um
Gamora especially in this movie went
from just being the love interest in the
first movie and just being this you know
uh whatever strong female character
that's just around a bunch of dumb dudes
which we've seen so much recently and so
in the second one she really comes into
her own and like we really get to know
her and like actually like uh relate to
her and and this her story with her
sister is really heartbreaking I I think
she's great and obviously Drax is like I
think Drax is my favorite I love Gamora
but I think Drake draxxas I love you
just gave like a full minute explaining
why you love Gamora so much they like
you have a Drax is
so cool I know I love them both yeah
it's a good point you bring about Gamora
is sort of like the uh it's it's like a
sitcom where she's the smart one and all
the dudes Hermione morons yeah she's
Hermione there you go first few movies I
think Gamora is the best character Drax
is my favorite character okay all right
yeah I mean look obviously I'm gonna
relate a lot to Peter because he also
references cheers and we have similar
taste in music but I feel like I'd be
shortchanging it if I didn't say rocket
he's just so God damn great choice he's
just cute and he's funny and he's
holding the wink the wink bit was hello
it's great yeah I don't think you're a
pretentious idiot
I like it much more in this one and the
first one he's a little b-i-t-c-h oh the
way that he was communicating two baby
Groot at the end of this movie might be
my other favorite scene oh that's when
he's trying to teach Baby Groot because
we want to ruin the movie Baby Groot is
very loyal but he's not necessarily the
best at pulling off and executing
instructions given to you so
and Rocket is just losing his mind he's
like that's literally the same thing you
just did I was dying laughing and this
is not me with like a bunch of herbal
medication this is just me enjoying the
movie and I don't know what I I remember
liking it but I'm not sure what was
wrong with me in 2017 as we've figured
out before I met Steph so maybe that was
the the the entry point into me being a
fully fledged adult I thought this movie
was so good
um let's do uh some other thoughts on
the MCU in general where I mentioned
that I'm a little fatigued with it as of
right now I just once we it this is my
thing with the Guardians I love these
Adventures but I also feel like opening
up the portals into space have kind of
hurt all the movies that take place on
Earth and all the movies we've seen and
I think the shows do the same kind of
harm to him because like when I was
trying to get into Loki it's like wait
all this stuff everybody already knew
this was gonna happen it just kind of
seen it it feels like the stakes get
reduced sometimes well you know
especially I remember watching Infinity
war and also feeling like MTV's Daria at
the end where everybody's turning into
dust and the entire movie theater was
like bawling you know just so emotional
and I'm like they come they come back
you know I thought you knew that I guess
they didn't read the comics right yeah
right so where are the stakes at right
like that's I mean it some of them are
good movies but most of them are all
leading up to the same thing bad dude uh
needs the stone right and so there's
only a few light Guardians uh too that
actually are about uh Concepts that are
relatable to humans versus just watching
some big action sequences which don't
get me wrong Winter Soldier is a
fantastic action movie right but the
rest of them not so much and this one I
think volume two maybe more so than we
gave a credit for initially does stand
on its own just as a movie and it
doesn't necessarily just serve as a
stepping stone stone to something else
right so I think that really holds up
upon re-watching it because it went
homecoming next and then Thor Ragnarok
was the movie after this and then I
think at the end of that movie maybe we
saw the Guardians at the end then that
set up Infinity War but I might be
getting my wires crossed there's a lot
of movies
um Steph where are you mentally
emotionally if I was mantis and and to
touch your shoulders okay what would I
sense about Steph's feelings towards the
MCU so I can't lie
um
I I do okay I'm a I'm an easy pleaser
with the MCU like if it's it's usually
good like and I'm usually good yeah but
I will say with the shows and the movies
luckily there's been kind of a pause in
the past few months I was feeling like
okay like this is I feel like the same
beats are getting hit but it's like
homework kind of I'm like I really have
to study for this next movie and I was
never good at school so but I'm excited
for I I am genuinely looking forward to
volume three yeah me too I'm like and
and that's predicated upon re-watching
this movie so the podcast did some good
for me hope we did something good for
all of our listeners out there last
question I have for you it's a little
bit of a trivia question because darina
brought up the snap where everybody's
disappearing and everybody knows like oh
it's so emotional for some people dorina
when Peter Parker is like I don't feel
so good Mr Stark whatever he says do you
know what baby Groot is saying
he says I am group but you know what he
said like they there's like a
translation I guess at like the MCU
confirmed Vin Diesel gets in English
translation script yeah yeah yeah do you
know what he was saying no but can we
guess yeah
oh he's saying it two rockets does he
say I love you
no I know
he as far as I'm as I believe there's no
Star Wars references that he makes trash
Panda
the amazing that was a great voice
um I believe what he's saying is
something along the lines of either dad
or daddy
puppy yeah that's really cute yeah which
means you can't kill rocket in volume
yeah you can't you can't
you can't but group's gonna be older
crude is gonna be older and that's one
of the many many post-credit teams we
get in this you guys are so worried
about a teenager and that's hysterical
it's amazing you guys are so worried
about somebody dying they always come
back they do always come back I mean
Gamora is back yeah but in a different
form yeah I mean still all right I feel
like this turned into two against one
really quick and baby groups across the
way staring at me and it's after I said
I would punch him off the cliff okay
guilty now then I'll piggyback it back
to you the other way because it's fine
they always come back I still can't seem
I can't watch a character I care that
much about Parish even if I know they're
coming back what if it's like when
everybody thought Chewie died for like a
hot second and ryza Skywalker it's like
oh my God oh my God I literally ripped
my lungs out that was the funniest scene
ever like you guys are that was stupid
everybody in the theater there's some
people in the theater reacted but I I
kept a stone face because I knew there's
no way they're going to kill Chewie I
did it
I thought he was gone
somebody shot your wookie when you were
a kid you've just never gotten over yeah
like anytime a horse dies in a movie or
a dog the never-ending story when the
poor thing is just like Jesus
I did not think we were gonna get to
never any story and then my mind goes to
Marley see that's so real oh God
this is a real death he doesn't turn
into dust he literally gets sucked by
the nothing yeah it just gets eaten by a
bunch of mud yeah that's a bummer when
you got when it's your time to go
speaking of childhood trauma and daddy
issues yeah yeah then nothing we got to
do the never-ending story on the show
sometime I have no idea what it's Tomato
Meter is but if it's anything less than
you know what I take that back yeah yeah
a long time
I don't know if it holds up it looks
great I'll say that okay all right I do
love Falcor yes flying dog yeah
fantastic music
yeah I think it's there's some weird
parts
we washed it and there's the ending
scene with that like little girl who's
like hello it's giving Teletubbies it's
very cool oh wow okay yeah all right
well we don't have a mailbag today so I
guess that served as our mailbag where
it was like me here Rotten Tomatoes the
little girl in never-ending story sucks
creepier now uh that is gonna do it for
us here on our movie talk segment so
let's close this out Brian
foreign
it is always fun being in the studio
with two of my best Pals so Steph dorina
uh is so fun talking Guardians with you
I'm sure there's going to be a lot of
reaction to Guardians volume three and I
will just tell everybody out there who's
about to go see the movie like this
there's many opportunities gonna get to
see the movie try to just enjoy it on
the first one don't be like Uncle Mark
watching volume two and thinking how
does this connect how is this going to
go to the Future what's the next movie
just enjoy this movie I don't know where
the hell the MCU is going I question a
lot of the motivations I think I'm just
going to go in this theater and have a
great time yeah I'm with you I'm just
gonna I just didn't get a will that it's
awesome co-sign I think the I think
Marvel should just be happy I'm actually
excited about one of their movies it's
been years there you go so you're pumped
for this one exactly what was the last
Marvel movie we're really excited for
crickets yeah I don't know what was the
last one I really loved I guess end game
was cool end game was cool yeah you
walked into that one ready but after
that I don't know if there's anything I
loved okay their spins like some good
movies in phase four like I really like
Shang Chi that black widow was fun oh
shangshi we really enjoy we really enjoy
it specifically because of Tony Lim and
yes also I'm not gonna lie to you I
loved love and Thunder
and and you should own that stuff good
for you that I'd be interested to
re-watch with my with my own eyes at
home again because again I remember
feeling sort of the same way I felt
leave in volume two which is where I was
laughing my ass off as a matter of fact
Jacqueline Coley and I were sitting next
to each other at the premiere of that
movie lucky to get invited to that
sitting there the goats were killing
killer we were dying we watching
together you were with the first goat
cry you were with the last goat cry yes
it was complete ridiculous British humor
mixed with Mel Brooks humor it's better
than most MCU movies I'm with you yeah
okay all right we gotta have you all
back to doing our official ranking or
maybe we can talk a little more MCU
movies next week when we have the ladies
returning for our after dark episode we
can talk about movies we talk about TV
we can talk about whatever else
including the wedding and either darino
were recently at we went to a big
nuptial ceremony and uh a lot of a lot
of do's and don'ts at that wedding
congratulations nothing to do with the
bride in the groom Mark and Julia are
fantastic everything else oh boy what a
fun wedding we got to talk about that is
going to be next week on Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong but before we say good night
here Steph where can all the cool kids
out there finding what you're working on
that's a bra just very simple very
simple you do you talk Star Wars you
talk all the fun nerdy stuff you also
give things a whirl so uh and you're
doing improv oh yeah I'm in improv 201
was I not supposed to no no you made it
to 201 I made it to 201
we'll talk about that dorina what else
are you working on um
if you want to find me on the internet
so I'm not there a lot but sometimes I
post uh you know we're all girls when
you get a wife from Dorena it's like 10
likes whoa it barely happened uh and
then also I make music and I DJ and now
you can find my band camp at bad bruja
oh wow okay all right we got a lot of
fun stuff to talk about after dark next
week so with that I will simply say I am
Mark Ellis reminder you can email us RT
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com anytime
let us know your thoughts on Guardians
Volume 2 volume 1 are you excited for
volume three what do you think of volume
three after you saw it and most
importantly what movies should we be
talking about on this show throw some TV
suggestions as well is an ever-ending
story at the top of your list let us
know that RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
all that good stuff share with your
friends next week is after dark and with
that my name is Mark Ellis for the whole
crew here at Rotten Tomatoes my co-host
Jacqueline Coley Doreen Ariano Steph
Sabra thank you and in the words of
David Hasselhoff we are group
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]